hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
you already know what I'm going to say
Sony have revealed the eight free games
for PlayStation Plus subscribers for the
month of December 2017 keep in mind Sony
wanted spending money in the run-up to
Christmas so December's ps+ offerings
won't blow your mind but it does offer a
good selection oh and stick around at
the end for an exclusive PS Plus beta
coming in early December it's monster
hunter world but we'll get to that very
soon as always let's look at the ps4
offerings first and straight off the bat
we have Darksiders to the death Finn
ative edition hmm I see what you did
there in this action role-playing game
you play as one of the Four Horsemen of
the Apocalypse none other than death
himself the narrative is about vengeance
for your brother but the star is really
there to pressure you into wrecking
hundreds and thousands of enemies
the combat mimics that of the God of War
series with lights and heavy attacks
with a few air bond version thrown in -
if you've ever played the modern Prince
of Persia games you will feel right at
home with the traversal and movement in
Darksiders 2 and the dungeons feel like
amateur rated version of the recent
Zelda titles with puzzles and objectives
to uncover the loop system is solid
hazard Rock and rewards activities with
new weapons to brutalize your enemies
this version of the game originally
released in 2015 and includes all the
deals that he ever made so expect to
pack away a few hours on this one it may
seem strange to get this title this
month but that's due to the upcoming
sequel
Darksiders 3 coming in 2018 so now is a
pretty good time to see if the dark
Sider series is for you next up is
somewhat of a family game in the shape
of kung-fu Panda showdown of the
legendary legends that's a bloody mouth
well anyway let's just say what it is
it's a Smash Brothers clone but wait
it's a damn good Smash Bros clone if
you're new to this genre it's a fighting
game in 2.5 D where you beat the living
daylights out of other players
alternatively smash them outside the
boundaries of the fight and pick up the
power-ups to get the edge in battle
simple but effective if you're having a
house party or a get-together with
friends then play this fighting on the
same cow
to bring these types of games to life
it's impossibly hard to find a
trustworthy review on Kung Fu Panda
showdown of the legendary legends so we
need your opinions if you played it
please let us know below your
PlayStation virtual reality game remains
the same rush of blood and on rail
shooter from the untold Dawn universe
and the play link title that's you is
here once again if you haven't already
downloaded it over the last 6 months
I've covered both titles in previous
video so let's move on over to the ps3
and first up X blaze lost memories which
would be I guess in the interactive
visual novel genre this is all about
narrative as the protagonist wanders
into a mysterious world known as the
phantom fields whilst looking for their
sister you'll be looking for memory
fragments to piece this one together and
progress through the story if you've
already played titles in the x-blade
series you'll know what to expect
the metacritic for this one is hovering
just above 60% next up on the ps3 is
siberia collection this version of the
game includes both siberia 1 and 2 and
focuses around kate walker who travels
across europe it's ultimately a
point-and-click adventure like those
found in Broken Sword Siberia picked up
a few Game of the Year awards in the
past due to its high-quality script and
acting if you're a fan of this type of
game then grab this one because you'll
get two games for the price of one over
on the Vita is former 8 which is also
available on your ps4 informer 8 you
maneuver a small exploration probe
stranded on an alien planet during a
life-and-death mission which of course
goes completely wrong this spherical
little blighter is here to recover lost
ship parts and save the day this one is
filled with adventure and puzzles and
actually achieved impressive review
scars from Pocket Gamer and God is a
geek hitting 8 out of 10
and the last offering for the month is
wanted car on the Vita this is one of
those numerous twin-stick shooters that
play so well on the Vita the premise is
pretty cool you play someone in a
mercenary agency sent to shoot aliens in
the face mad dog is a dual wielding
beast and arena is like an interstellar
sorcerer this one will be pretty good
for a train journey on your Vita but the
reviews indicate that this should be
avoided IGN gave it five point five out
of ten but wait there's more
more thing those of us on PlayStation
Plus during December can access the
exclusive beta for Monster Hunter World
running from December the 9th to
December the 12th you can jump in and
experience the game which releases in
January PS Plus subscribers will receive
three different quests which can be
played all on your lonesome or
cooperatively I freaking can't wait for
this one I'd love to know what you think
about monster hunter world so there we
have a PS Plus for December I know it's
not the greatest in the world but there
are a few gems in the rough and
hopefully something for everyone my
highlights you know what it is my
highlight is monster hunter world I
cannot wait for that game I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time